you
[Music]
in our morning rounds is Breast Cancer
Awareness Month this october draws to a
close we're focusing on the unintended
consequences of breast cancer treatment
more than 3.8 million breast cancer
survivors live in the united states
recent advancements in early detection
and treatment really have saved many
lives but those treatments may also
increase a woman's risk of
cardiovascular disease in fact it's
heart disease not cancer reoccurrence
that is the number one cause of death
for breast cancer survivors and women
overall dr. tara nurullah is a
cardiologist at northwell health joins
us more on this I think a lot of people
will be surprised to hear this Tara good
morning to you good morning Gail yes in
about 10% of breast cancer patients the
same chemotherapy and radiation
treatments that zap cancer cells can
also damage the heart it can happen
during treatment or years afterward now
an emerging field called cardio oncology
has evolved to protect the hearts of
cancer patients both during and after
treatment to make sure they live full
lives after defeating cancer four months
into her fight against stage 2 breast
cancer
Andrea Chen Frannie learned she had a
new health challenge to conquer it
really did feel like another punch you
know that where you've been punched a
couple times after recovering from a
mastectomy andrea received chemotherapy
to attack her breast cancer not knowing
that it was also attacking her heart it
was a little bit of a surprise
especially because I wasn't feeling
anything you were otherwise young and
healthy had no history of any heart
problems no no everything was was fine
an echocardiogram revealed the 40 year
old had heart failure and was among the
tens of thousands of breast cancer
patients who develop heart disease each
year dr. Chau dang is Andrea's
oncologist at Memorial sloan-kettering
during treatment we actually can see a
cardiac dysfunction namely heart failure
for some where our patients dr. Tang
teamed up with a cardiologist
prescribing medication to protect
Andrea's heart so she would be strong
enough to finish chemotherapy so the
feel of Cardiology is
a feel that is growing I think we're all
working very well together to take care
of our patients not only to improve
their cancer outcomes as they survive
but to improve their cardiovascular
outcomes as they age breast cancer
treatment puts the heart at risk in
several ways chemotherapy can damage the
heart muscle that pumps blood leading to
heart failure and radiation can disrupt
normal heart rhythm and damage both the
lining around the heart and the heart
valves but the biggest risk from
radiation is the development of early
and accelerated coronary artery disease
which raises the risk of heart attack
while some women have no symptoms others
experience shortness of breath chest
pain or decreased ability to exercise
what we should not be telling our
patients is don't get the very
treatments that make you beat the cancer
in the first place
dr. Javed Mosley he directs the cardio
oncology program at Vanderbilt
University the treatments are effective
but now the issue is how do we give the
drugs more safely but how do we prevent
heart disease that can develop as a
result of the very treatments that save
a patient's life at what point would a
woman be at risk of being affected by
the treatment she's receiving per breast
cancer it can happen years to even a
decade after completion of treatment and
it is this part that I think we as a
medical community need to raise more
awareness and do a better job of
screening for three years after
completing treatment Andrea's heart is
strong again but she will be monitored
for any lingering effects of the
chemotherapy for the rest of her life
once they've completed treatment cancer
patients should ask doctors to give them
a detailed record of their chemo and
radiation dosages to discuss with their
primary care doctor or cardiologist they
should also speak to them about how to
recognize symptoms of heart disease and
take preventive measures to lower their
risk I do feel for Andrea because it
does seem like a one-two punch and you
mentioned she didn't feel any symptoms
so how do you know if you're at risk
well the big key is awareness awareness
awareness on the clinician and providers
side in fact the American Heart
Association put out its first scientific
stage
in 2018 about the intersection of breast
cancer and cardiovascular disease and
awareness on the patient side so they
should know what their cardiovascular
risk factors are how much and what type
of chemotherapy or targeted therapy or
hormone therapy they got how much
radiation they received and have this
conversation with their doctor because
we're very good about kind of
shepherding patients through their
cancer treatment and really monitoring
them but it's that period afterwards
when they leave when they become a
survivor that we really don't do
something right kendricks for other
types of cancers affect the heart too or
is it just for breast cancer absolutely
you know so many people have said
they've never even heard of this field
of cardio oncology but this is a big
field and it's not just breast cancer it
is chemotherapy and other agents used
for different types of cancers radiation
you know patients who've had Hodgkin's
disease or may have gotten radiation to
the chest for that so this is a big
field so always good to know your chemo
or radiation history and just discuss it
with your doctor Tara thanks for raising
our awareness and I'm sure we appreciate
it